écoles bars restaurants commerces non
alimentaires depuis début janvier ils
sont tous fermés en allemagne
s'ajoute un télétravail dans la mesure
du possible une stricte limitation des
rencontres objectif contrer l'épidémie
de kovy 19 qui a connu une recrudescence
au début de l'année
le gouvernement allemand a préféré agir
vite avec un nouveau confinement des
mesures qui semblent déjà porter leurs
fruits nous ne pouvons pas rester dans
ce confinement dur tout l'hiver
notre société ne le supporterais pas
bien il n'est pas possible de se
prononcer avec certitude sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouverons le 14 février
les chiffres sont encourageants nous
observons une tendance significative à
la baisse concernant les nouvelles
infections
le taux d'incidence est en effet en
baisse en allemagne le nombre moyen de
nouvelles infections pour 100000
habitants est passé à 87 ce jeudi et se
rapproche du seuil des 50 souhaité par
les autorités
à titre de comparaison le taux
d'incidence en france est de 213 pour
100000 habitants et de 700 au portugal
l'un des pays les plus touchés la
campagne de vaccination allemande est
aussi efficace avec plus de 2,7 millions
de personnes qui ont reçu une première
dose
l'allemagne est le pays de l'union
européenne le plus en avance des
chiffres qui amène à réfléchir sur un
possible d confinement des personnes
vaccinées une possibilité aussitôt
réfutée il faut espérer que les taux
d'infection diminueront considérablement
grâce à la vaccination
toutefois des infections continueront à
se produire malgré les vaccinations
cela doit être clairement communiqué les
demandes d'exemption des restrictions la
liberté des personnes vaccinées ne sont
pas très utiles ici
elle suggère la fausse sécurité selon
laquelle les personnes vaccinées ne
présente pas de risque d'infection
si un déconfinement semble encore dans
les papiers du gouvernement allemand
rien n'est encore fait concrètement
plusieurs virologues ont mis en garde
contre une sortie prématurée du
confinement en raison du risque posé par
les variantes du virus plus
transmissible
de plus l'allemagne est le dixième pays
le plus touché au monde par le cos vide
en terme de
mortalité avec plus de soixante mille
décès depuis le début de l'épidémie